留学っていう名前はその学問的な学校は終わって日本に帰ればでもうちょっと日がある
んで自分の英語力を高
試すわけじゃないんですけどい充実のいろんなところが待っています
半年分の荷物全部一人でプラ避けながら食べしてるんで
戦後今正直しんどいんですけど意外と
英語通じるようになりました
じゃあは分からないんですけど
一応源氏の人はなにいってれこうも聞こえるし何か言いたいときも家 c
一応コミュニケーションを取れるレベルには達したと思っています
今いるのは某ますって言う
髪のケアはもっさやんけー技術のすぐ南にある
海がすぐそこに見える見えないんですけど
って感じなんで
なあ5留学は生後が失敗怒って言ったらわかんないんですけど
別に失敗も成功もないと
持っています様するのが一番大事ですし英語を身に付けることも大事だし
2つを作ることも大事ですよ世界中に
一応全部ほどよくできたんで
すごい
よかったなと思ってラセル行くわっ
また現像っていうことです本当に組なそう
はっはっは
ぽって
ねって年降った
ん
やれ tan
いざんした
出れなくなってもらった入れなきゃって思ったん
ペアキーです
美味しいてさー
俺はやっぱり成長しねえ
アイドルヘアーレースむー
完全いもうもう俺の両津ですよ
シングルなんでそんな白く内村とにベッドが一つあるぐらいで
ここの照明は壊れています
本当にこんな感じですこれ限っ
引き返していきます
持っています
た
なんでいつもこんな味噌するんだ
ついてくれますし愛嬌とオープンととは
始めます